foreign
Is With Us in Atlanta hi Chris welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call so
just a little bit of background I'm 42.
um I am
hospital and
um I have been haven't been debt free
all my life probably last 15 years but
um I feel guilty every time I spend
money we have 401k savings we invest
money I still work my wife still works
but it pains me to spend anything over a
hundred dollars sometimes
um so I was wondering if you could tell
me do you still feel that even after 30
years of being debt free or whatnot
because I feel it our house is paid off
we have no payments and I still get that
clinching in my stomach every time we
have to go do anything I can't relax and
have fun I was wondering if you could
tell me maybe how you feel or if you
felt the same way after you got out of
debt and built built a bunch of wealth
it's not it's not guilt it's fear
that makes sense
and what that is is Dr John deloney
would say your body is remembering
being broke
and it's telling you that that your
spending is a threat it's a threat it's
a threat it's a threat and so your fear
activates
that's what happened to me anyway
even 10 years after you got debt free
not 10 years but for a while it did and
I I what I did is just what you've done
I just recognized it was happening and I
kind of like you're doing I started
asking the question what the Flip's
going on
I mean what's wrong with you you got a
million dollars will you yeah pissing
and moaning about going to the grocery
store for you know I apologize my wife
crazy yeah I mean that's what that's
what that was me talking to me not you
okay but I'm just saying I had to kind
of go okay and again I'll I'll just
bring I'll Channel my inner deloney God
help us but um yeah but the uh you're
doing good uh but but the you know the
the thing it
um
I had to do two things one is I had to
say all right facts are my friends
okay so what is your net worth Chris
I would say probably 2.2 and you're 42
years old and you're 100 debt free and
your household income is what
uh round two
two seventy five okay so let's just be
realistic for a second if we took 200
000 dollars
and hundred dollar bills
out of your net worth
and put it in the fireplace and burned
it
he's now got cold sweats Jade I know he
does if we did that yeah if we did that
your life is not going to change one
percent
really that's a fact no that's a fact
other than the nervous breakdown that
you would have but I'm just saying but
the but you know what I'm saying
mathematically are you as okay with 2
million as you are with 2.2 you are we
know that to be true that is a fact
it's a fact so when you go
and and and and go on a nice vacation
and drop 10 grand for your poor wife
who's put up with you
trust me I just did that and I had a
nervous break I know I know but the
reason is you're you're acting like your
your fear mechanism is activating as if
you're broke and the facts tell us that
that is a false signal
and can I take it one further Chris
because I kind of relate to some of what
you're saying um on Sam and I's journey
through this debt-free journey and then
some I've had to go there's been certain
moments that I've had to go back and
find where that emotion is coming from
and I've had to think back on what what
was the instance where that was ignited
like okay it was when I asked for lunch
money and and someone blew up on me
right or it was because I did this and
that was the first time that actually
there's a phrase you heard yes we ain't
got no money
that was a phrase I heard growing up
Chris and there's been so many times in
my life I've had to go back and find
where that came from and speak to it
directly and go hey if if I if I buy
this pair of tennis shoes right now it's
not going to break the budget No One's
Gonna yell at me no one's got you know
what I've had to go back and say that if
I buy what I would like to have for
lunch at the grocery store there's no
guilt there I'm not going to throw the
budget off the family's not going to pay
for I've had to say that and I think
sometimes my guess is that there's some
things that have happened that have
caused some trigger in you and you've
got to go back and identify that and
honestly speak directly to it and say
hey I'm not there anymore
another one another place we've dealt
with this Chris was
um once I kind of started getting past
it the fear the sheer it's not fear is
sheer Terror that my wife Sharon felt
when we went bankrupt and lost
everything and we had a brand new baby
and a toddler and the lights got cut off
if I even have a similar body language
or tone 30 years later
towards spending like the emergency fund
and it makes it activates that it
triggers that inside of her we have to
we have to just time out and back up
because she has to start breathing again
it because she I can I can she's she
feels like I'm doing what I did when I
went broke for just a nanosecond and it
activates and all of these lights light
up in her in her uh her physical body
changes I mean her her she gets pissed
off from being really terrified again
and it just doesn't yeah yeah and it it
activates all fear and anger are best
friends they run around together and so
um terrible feeling yeah it is it is but
here's the point okay number one facts
are your friends
all you gotta do is when you start doing
that you just have to stop and go now
wait a minute that's not real
this is this is fear that's called false
evidence appearing real this is a this
is a falsehood us spending this money is
not irresponsible and it's not going to
break our family and you just have to
talk to yourself and build the muscle
then of doing that the other thing you
can do is you give a very specific
process put in place and go okay like
for instance Sharon and I we do not
spend
or give more than a thousand dollars
without talking to each other and if
it's more than a thousand dollars we
wait overnight also
we breathe now do we have to do that
mathematically today absolutely not we
got all kinds of margin but we do it as
an act of respect to each other to keep
from activating those scars those wounds
from having gone broke and uh you know
it was the first five years after going
broke for me and even today I'm telling
you that we still if we're if we don't
abide by some certain processes that are
safety valves then we can still step
back over that line and their emotional
processes they're not mathematical
processes because again we could give
away I mean we could take X number of
dollars and put it in the middle of the
floor and burn it and it wouldn't affect
our lives we've got the money it's not
that's not the issue so mathematically
it's not the problem but but the action
the body language the tone the process
used seems impulsive
irresponsible out of control immature
and it feels like the old days that's
right and boy to light your butt up it
will I mean it's just another component
to when we say money is I mean it's
behavioral and it's behavioral in the
moment but it's also taking to account
the behaviors you did beforehand and you
feel that and you're still connected to
those and so when you get in a moment
where you're like why am I freaking out
right now you know when I know for Sam
if the bank account used to hit a
certain number he'd start being like
okay okay we gotta go do something okay
and and that's the way it is we can't
act like these things didn't have an
effect on us mentally and that that
behavior didn't affect us because it
does now I am much more healed yes 30
years ago
than I was 30 months after the
bankruptcy yes you know 30 years later
versus 30 months later and so you should
go through a healing process but it's
also just wise to acknowledge what's
really going on here and then number one
we're gonna say oh that's not real
number two you look at the actual ratios
and go okay we're not being
irresponsible so why am I feeling you
know and then you learn to you practice
your way through normal feelings versus
wounded feelings